[موسيقى]
المسيرات الرخيصه سلاح ايران المفضل
ارسلتها طهران الى كل مكان حيث ميليشياتها
في سوريا والعراق واليمن ولعب دورا في حرب
الوكاله لتزييم الموقف وتهديد الممرات
المائيه لتنفيذ مشروعا الخاص
المسيرات الانتحاريه التي تجمعها ايران
تستخدمها كورقه ضغط لتحقيق مكاسب في
المفاوضات النوويه او لرفع العقوبات
[موسيقى]
لطالما كان الغرب يفكر باليه للحد من سلوك
ايران ومسيراتها وما حدث في اصفهان كان
رساله لتغيير في الاستراتيجيه
مسيرات من داخل البلاد تضرب موقع عسكريا
هذه المره في ايران وجود خلايا واختراق
داخل ايران مساله تتصاعد حيث كان البرنامج
النووي الايراني هدفا لمحاولات تخريب
متكرره في عام 2020 اغتيل كبير العلماء في
البلاد وتعرضت منشاه طنز النوويه لاضرار
الجزئيه وفي العام نفسه تم ضرب منشات
الكراج
مسيرات اصفهان ضربت مصنع اسلحه حكوميه
الايرانيه في وسط مدينه اصفهان والذي
تصادف ايضا ان يكون مركزا لانتاج مسيرات
يقال انها ترسل الى القوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
تصريحات اوكرانيا لطهران بعد الهجوم باننا
حذرناكم ورد روسيا العنيف لادانه الهجوم
كلها اسباب تؤكد هذا التوجه وقبلها تحدث
اعلام امريكيون عن ان اسرائيل هي من نفذت
الهجوم ومهما يكن من امر فانه جوما اصفهان
يشكل نقطه تحول في المواجهه بين الغرب
وطهران بنقل المواجهه الى داخل ايران
نفسها التي تواجه احتجاجات ضد النظام الذي
فقد الحاضنه الشعبيه له